[Musique]
ce week end à l'antenne de paris du
département de la réunion les
préparatifs vont bon train au programme
une distribution de repas aux étudiants
réunionnais en mobilité
quelques heures plus tôt dans la cuisine
de découverte réunion la famille payet
s'activent au menu un repas traditionnel
ressourçant la charente d'aigus hongrie
saucisses et cammas année et en dc4
adapte donc nos lacs leurs oreilles
saucisses n'aura de riz et lentilles et
les paillettes ont la chance d'être en
famille mais aurélienne se rappelle du
grand réconfort venue du pays
à son arrivée en métropole n'est pas
vrai c'est vrai que j'attendais que ça
va de la réunion c'était quelque chose
qui à toi enfin qui a toi qui es tu toi
alors à l'appel du département ils n'ont
pas hésité à mettre à disposition leurs
savoir-faire pays
dans cet élan du coeur on est imprégné
des sarts on aime faire accuser une
poisse et emploi pour ses amis c'est
naturel grand plaisir ni vu ça c'est
comme si un peu c'est comme si c'était
votre enfant doit effectivement donc la
donne et loin de leurs familles
pour nous c'est un petit plus mais
comme beaucoup le pensent beaucoup j'ai
fait au total dans toute la france
soixante restaurateurs traiteurs et
associations se sont mobilisées pour
l'événement
retour à l'antenne de paris du
département où les étudiants patiente
chacun est venu récupérer un sac rempli
de souvenirs donc à naples alors vous
avez gâteau patate à chartres et le riz
le grain est un rendez vous essentiel
est symbolique pour chacun j'ai passé
mon beaucoup l'occasion de cuisiner
réunionnais beaucoup donc là oui ça fait
quand même plaisir de pouvoir goûter
tout ça un peu de chaleur dans sept ans
un peu morose et ça réchauffe le coeur
moi j'adore la réunion j'adore tout ce
qui se passe à l'avenir du coup bon
jusqu à ce qu il ya à la réunion ici bas
c'est important dans le respect des
restrictions sanitaires
chacun s'est rendu dans le lieu de
distribution le plus proche de son
domicile
une bouffée d'oxygène dans ce contexte
difficile pour tous et particulièrement
les étudiants réunionnais cas
symbolisent allemand que certains
étudiants ont pu avoir durant ce temps
de compliments
on est vraiment très isolés surtout les
étudiants donc c'est vraiment très
gentils du département de me donner
ce report serait constant un peu
considéré du coup oui voilà encore une
opération réussie pour la directrice de
l'antenne maureen fut à l'image de bien
vivre ensemble de la région
c'est à l'image de notre esprit
fraternel et solidaire
de fraternité ça se trouve par cette
action par cette générosité de nouveaux
restaurateurs la détresse psychologique
des étudiants
ça avait jugé d'actualité nationale il
était important pour le développement
vous êtes présent aux côtés des
étudiants présents à travers cet
événement mais pas seulement
depuis plus de 40 ans le département
s'engage pour les étudiants réunionnais
comme nous l'expliquent
est ce là une moquette depuis la reine
des premières zones de tes mises en
place après par complication donc en
1948 il y avait que deux étudiants
réunionnais qui étaient concernés à
cette époque et aujourd'hui nous sommes
passés à onze mille étudiants qui sont
aidés par le département
donc chacun c'est une à deux permanentes
structurels en trois volets lavaud et
par comtal doit compléter la bourse
nationale
c'est par le crous seront elles pour
justement encourager des parcours
d'excellence vous intervenant au niveau
de la location de scolarité et la
troisième aide concerne des chambres
universitaires
aujourd'hui l'égalité des chances fait
que nous avons beaucoup d fuyant
réunionnais qui donc n'ont pas les
moyens de se rendre en métropole et dans
les pays l'union européenne voire
étrangers donc nous est lui à raison on
décidé donc successivement qu'accès
majorité en place
1982 de poursuivre cette aide et je dois
pas être surtout de l'amplifier puisque
le montant total des aides avoisiner 20
millions d'euros par an dès l'arrivée de
la pandémie
kovy de 19 l'ensemble des élus à
l'unanimité ont décidé de mettre en
place progressivement ses réactions
la première action a consisté à
anticiper sur le versement justement de
la brosse départementale la deuxième
action a consisté à offrir envoyer un
colis pays avec 10 produits pour 1200
d'étudiants qui avaient répondu
positivement
et puis là une décision extrêmement
importante qui était prise par
l'assemblée départementale donc
récemment le 24 mars dernier consistant
à octroyer une aide une prime de
résilience à 3000 dessus de son
diffusion mancier en mobilité
et puis voilà
la dernière belle action ce jour en tout
cas qui étaient initiative antenne de
paris donc c'est ce qu'a mis et union
j'ai envie d'y à sa carrière l'union un
cari la réunion pour faire en sorte que
tous ces étudiants qui sont essaimé dans
toute la métropole voire à l'étranger
des pays européennes puissent se
retrouver autour d'un carry il faut
saluer bien sûr face au prestataire
j'ai des droits les bénévoles mais
également notre équipe a permis de
l'antenne de paris qui a bien travaillé
pour la permettre aux étudiants ce
moment de chaleur de retrouvailles
également et faire en sorte que la
solidarité réunionnaise
donc soit transporté depuis depuis le
windows qu'un seul dans une cinquantaine
de villes de l'hexagone 1200 jeunes
réunionnais se sont inscrits pour
bénéficier de cette action
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]